.
Wo habe ich jetzt ...
Thomas, weisst du, ob du
die letzte Rolle aufgebraucht hast?
Ich meine,
das letzte Papier auf der Rolle.
Bin ich der Küchendienst? Nein.
(Sarkastisch) Schön.
- Ja.
Bei den Auswanderern in Kanada
liegen die Nerven blank.
Ich denke nicht, dass es besser
wäre, wenn wir in der Schweiz wären.
Nein, das sagt hier niemand.
- Ich weiss.
Aber du sagtest,
dass du gern zurückkehren würdest.
Ne, das habe ich auch nie gesagt.
- Aber du weisst, was ich meine.
Ich würde es so, wie wir es machten,
nicht wieder tun.
Ein luxuriöses Gästehaus am Meer.
Das ist der Traum von
Barbara Hasenböhler und Thomas Range.
Nach Startschwierigkeiten
ist der Umbau der Villa
endlich auf gutem Weg.
Das ist unser Schlaf-Wohnzimmer.
Es ist vielleicht 3 m auf 4 m gross.
Dann aber
bricht sich Barbara den Knöchel.
Warte, warte.
Und obwohl
noch kein einziges Zimmer fertig ist,
haben sie bereits
jede Menge Buchungen.
The reservation is made.
It's under your name.
Ich freue mich darauf, die Tür auf-
zuschliessen und Gäste zu empfangen.
Im sonnigen Griechenland
wollen Alain Aegerter und Anita Thomi
Ferien für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Ah!
Doch alles kommt anders:
Ein verheerender Waldbrand
vernichtet das Haus der Auswanderer.
Das ist
unser ehemaliges Schlafzimmer.
Sie verlieren alles.
Trotzdem geben sie nicht auf
und beginnen mit dem Wiederaufbau.
Gut. Noch ein bisschen?
Auch das Tourismusgeschäft
wollen sie starten:
Sie bieten
eine erste Erlebnisreise an.
Ich schrieb, dass die Unterkunft
wegen des Brandes
noch nicht bei uns ist.
(Hans) Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Mehr Selbstbestimmung
sucht Familie Rotzler.
In Schweden
übernehmen sie eine Ferienanlage
und mit ihr jede Menge Arbeit.
Als Erstes
renovieren sie die Gaststube.
Immer mit dabei: Nachbar Ulf.
Es macht Spass, mit ihm zusammen-
zuarbeiten. Das ist gegenseitig.
Very good light.
- Hello, nice to meet you.
Schon kommen die ersten Gäste.
Familie Rotzler
muss sich als Gastgeber bewähren.
Gerade halten.
Smaklig maltid.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Sieben Wochen später. Sieben Wochen,
in denen sich manches verändert hat.
Wo darf ich es hinstellen?
- Hierhin, neben den Tisch.
Vielleicht mag Fiona mithelfen.
Die Finken hängen wir
auch an die Garderobe.
Aber leider
sind die Finken etwas eng.
Du sagtest, sie wären nur oben eng.
Probiere sie an,
sonst holen wir neue.
Dann trägst du diese zu Hause.
Für Tochter Fiona
beginnt morgen die Schule,
aber ausgerechnet jetzt
ist die Sechsjährige krank.
Sie war die ganze Nacht wach, musste
erbrechen und hatte hohes Fieber.
Am Freitag waren wir
nochmals bei der Lehrerin.
Fiona sagte,
sie freue sich nun ein bisschen,
aber sie ist bestimmt auch nervös.
Es ist doof, dass sie nicht fit ist.
Damit rechnete ich überhaupt nicht.
Bist du morgen ein Einhorn-Mädchen?
- Ja.
Überall sind Einhörner.
Jetzt haben wir mal
alles vorbereitet und hoffen,
dass es dir heute Nachmittag
schon viel besser geht.
Nach dem erfolgreichen Testlauf
mit ersten Gästen
war Familie Rotzler nicht untätig.
Sie haben
den defekten Hot Pot abgebaut
und durch einen neuen Kessel ersetzt.
* Ruhige Musik *
In der Gaststube
haben sie Teppichboden verlegt
und alles frisch mit Fundstücken
aus der Anlage dekoriert.
Jetzt fehlt nicht mehr viel.
Schon bald wollen sie das Restaurant
nicht nur für Hotelgäste,
sondern auch
für Laufkundschaft öffnen.
Trotz der vielen Arbeit:
Den Umzug nach Mittelschweden bereut
der ehemalige Qualitätsmanager nicht.
Es ist bereits extrem viel wert,
mit den Kindern aufstehen,
mit ihnen zu Mittag
und zu Abend essen zu können.
Wenn man arbeitet, sind sie
vielleicht nicht immer dabei,
aber sie sind irgendwo in der Nähe.
Das ist ein riesiger Vorteil,
den ich extrem zu schätzen weiss.
Papa?
- Hm?
* Kian plappert. *
Was ist, Kian?
Mal schauen, ob es reicht.
Heute möchte Jonas
einen Sichtschutz bauen -
mit Holz aus dem eigenen Wald.
Das grosse Grundstück
war auch ein Grund,
warum sich Familie Rotzler für ein
Leben in Schweden entschieden hat.
Ah, es geht nicht.
Bringst du sie in Gang?
Zuerst den Motor, hier.
Ja, perfekt.
So, komm.
Papa, du musst mich hochheben.
Ich kann dich bei der Arbeit
doch nicht hochheben.
Als Unternehmer können die Rotzlers
den Tag selbst gestalten
und tun, was sie für wichtig
erachten - ohne Chef im Nacken.
Das geniessen sie besonders.
* Verträumte Musik *
Sabrina möchte mit Kian und Liana
Beeren sammeln.
Diese wachsen überall
auf ihrem Grundstück.
Nun kannst du in den Wald reingehen.
- Hier?
Dort warst du noch nicht, oder?
- Nein.
Silvana,
Kians Patentante, kommt mit.
Sie ist eine Woche bei Rotzlers zu
Besuch und unterstützt die Familie.
Hü, Gotti.
(Lachend)
Kian schwingt die Peitsche.
Schau, Moos.
- Ja, hier ist ganz viel Moos.
Dort sind sicher bereits Blaubeeren.
Dort sind ein paar Blaubeeren.
Hast du schon eine gesehen, Liana?
Obwohl die Familie erst einen Sommer
in Schweden verbracht hat,
ist das alte Leben im solothurnischen
Witterswil schon ganz weit weg.
Ich dachte immer,
dass die Kinder oder ich
etwas Heimweh haben würden.
Aber bisher hatten wir
noch keine grössere Krise.
Natürlich vermisst Liana
ab und zu ihre Freundin,
aber das grosse Vermissen
blieb bisher aus,
weil wir uns einfach wohlfühlen.
Schau,
ich habe noch einige gefunden.
Schwups.
Komm.
Hier sind unsere nächsten Nachbarn.
- Ah ja.
Hier wohnen Ulf und Eva.
- Ah, sie wohnen hier?
Wir sehen sie
eigentlich fast jeden Tag.
Immer noch relativ oft.
Auf dem griechischen Peloponnes
steht der Frühling vor der Tür.
Seit gut acht Monaten leben
Anita Thomi und Alain Aegerter
schon in der Einliegerwohnung
von Holländer Hans.
Und nicht nur sie,
sondern auch 15 Reptilien.
Draussen ist es für die Tiere
immer noch zu frostig.
Lucy, komm.
Es war ein extrem kalter Winter.
Wenn es regnet,
regnet es unglaublich stark.
Dann kann man
eigentlich nicht nach draussen.
Wir waren schon oft in der Wohnung.
Wir freuen uns darauf,
wieder ein eigenes Zuhause zu haben.
* Pfiff *
Wir brauchen mehr Platz
für die Tiere. Das geht nicht.
Wir brauchen etwas anderes.
Aber das wird schon werden.
* Mediterrane Musik *
Die Schweizer sind dankbar,
dass Hans sie aufgenommen hat.
Trotzdem macht sich
bei den beiden langsam
so etwas wie Lagerkoller breit.
Ihr sehnlichster Wunsch:
so schnell wie möglich wieder
auf ihrem Grundstück zu wohnen.
Was noch fehlt, sind
die Hilfsgelder für den Wiederaufbau.
Schon vor Wochen
stellten sie den Antrag
bei den griechischen Behörden.
Zumindest die Löcher
für die Schildkrötenteiche
konnten sie bereits ausheben lassen.
Und das Sanitärhaus
ist ebenfalls fast fertig.
Gut versteckt:
die wichtigste Neuerung.
Wir liessen ...
... aus diesem Betonfundament
einen Wassertank bauen.
Darin haben 30'000 l Wasser Platz.
Im Sommer können wir damit
die bestehenden Teiche kühlen,
falls sie zu warm werden sollten.
Falls wieder mal
ein Feuer ausbrechen sollte,
hätten wir die Möglichkeit -
30'000 l sind zwar nicht viel,
aber besser als nichts -
vor Ort zu löschen.
Du willst, dass er längs im Lot ist,
nicht wahr?
Heute wollen sie
den Wohnwagen ausrichten,
den sie aus der Schweiz mitbrachten.
Stopp.
Wenn es wieder wärmer ist, wollen sie
ihn als Büro und Schlafplatz nutzen.
Das Problem:
Der Wohnwagen steht viel zu schräg.
So.
Wir müssen flache Steine unterlegen,
ihn runterlassen,
die Steine rausnehmen,
ihn anheben, Steine unterlegen,
ihn runterlassen und anheben.
Möchtest du,
dass ich flache Steine suche?
Passt der Stein
rechts von dir nicht?
Nein, der ist scheisse,
das ist ein Keil.
Du willst ...
- ... flache.
In welcher Grösse und Dicke?
Er muss diese Fläche abdecken
und flach sein.
Wie dick?
So dick,
wie der Pneu auf dem Boden aufliegt.
Du möchtest also einen dickeren?
Warte,
ich kann zwei aufeinanderlegen.
Alain will machen,
Anita erst mal überlegen.
Jetzt rollt er
und das verklemmt sich - praktisch.
Darf ich mal etwas sagen?
Das mit den Rädern
klappt einfach nicht.
Wir müssen etwas unter die Streben
legen, das von der Höhe her passt.
Ja, aber es ist sehr hoch.
Wir brauchen
einen 28 cm hohen Stein.
* Mediterrane Musik *
Du kannst ihn mal ausrichten.
Ich hole den Nächsten.
So.
Das klappt wohl nicht.
Er neigt sich zu sehr nach unten.
Nach 2 Std. Steine schleppen,
geht es plötzlich ganz schnell.
Anita merkte,
dass vorn noch Füsse sind.
Daher war es viel einfacher.
Ich besass noch nie einen Wohnwagen
und wusste das nicht.
Camper haben nur hinten Füsse.
Gut, nun steht er
einigermassen gerade ...
... und jetzt harren wir der Dinge.
Möchtest du noch einen Kaffee?
- Nicht unbedingt.
Ich hatte heute
schon zu viel Kaffee.
23 °C und Sonnenschein.
Auf Prince Edward Island
beginnt die Hauptsaison.
Nur noch vier Tage,
dann wollen Thomas Range und Barbara
Hasenböhler ihr Gästehaus eröffnen.
Doch noch ist nicht alles fertig.
(Englisch)
Ohne Angabe von Gründen,
nehme ich an.
"I'm not coming today."
That's die Angabe der Gründe.
Es ist Wochenende
und die Handwerker machen frei.
Barbara und Thomas aber
müssen durcharbeiten -
wie schon so oft in letzter Zeit.
Es wäre gut, einen Tag frei zu haben
und etwas zu tun,
worauf ich wirklich Lust habe,
z.B. mich aufs Fahrrad setzen
oder am Strand laufen gehen.
Das würde bestimmt viel bringen
und ich könnte meine Batterien
wieder aufladen.
Aber man muss realistisch sein:
Im Moment
liegt das einfach nicht drin.
Die Aussenarbeiten
an der 570 m2 grossen Villa
sind fast abgeschlossen.
* Lockere Musik *
Schon für Gäste herrichten konnten
Barbara und Thomas die Bibliothek.
Über Monate
diente sie ihnen als Schlafzimmer.
Barbaras Knöchel
ist noch nicht ganz verheilt,
aber zumindest der Gips ist weg.
Endlich kann sich die 45-Jährige
wieder frei im ganzen Haus bewegen.
Die beiden wohnen jetzt
gleich neben der Küche.
Sie wollen für Gäste erreichbar sein.
Das ist sozusagen unser Zuhause.
Hier sind unsere Küche, unser
Wohnzimmer und unser Schlafzimmer.
Aber zurzeit
sind es Abstellkammern -
wie alle Räume hier.
Ihr eineinhalb Zimmer grosser
Rückzugsraum ist schon ausgestattet.
Ganz im Gegensatz
zu den Hotelzimmern.
Neben verschiedenen Details
fehlt noch etwas ganz Entscheidendes:
die Möbel.
Fast die gesamte Einrichtung
liess Barbara in China
auf Mass herstellen.
Unser Container
mit allen Möbeln ist zurzeit -
nein, nicht zurzeit,
sondern seit knapp vier Wochen -
in Halifax gestrandet.
Das bedeutet,
dass wir seit dreieinhalb Wochen
auf glühenden Kohlen sitzen.
Da wir in den letzten Monaten
so viel Mist erlebt haben -
und in den letzten drei Wochen
noch viel mehr -
ist unsere Freude etwas getrübt.
Ausgerechnet ihr Container
wurde vom Zoll in Halifax
aus Tausenden ausgewählt.
Jetzt wird er
einer Sonderprüfung unterzogen.
Diese kostet nicht nur Zeit,
sondern auch viel Geld:
10'000 kanadische Dollar obendrauf.
* Er seufzt. *
Soll ich dir helfen?
Ihnen bleibt nur eins:
Augen zu und gemeinsam durch.
So, es ist wie neu.
Die Grundstabilität ist vorhanden.
8 kg hält es aus.
He, good cookie,
du bist ein Produkttester.
Auf der Ferienanlage Skalsjögarden
in Schweden
ist Nachbar Ulf vorbeigekommen -
unangemeldet.
Im Anhänger ein Schneemobil.
Ulf möchte es reinigen und
bei Jonas in der Garage einlagern,
so wie all die Jahre zuvor.
Im Restaurant kümmert sich Jonas
um letzte Details.
Wäre es wie vor ein paar Wochen,
stünde Ulf nun an Jonas' Seite.
Doch die Beziehung zwischen
Familie Rotzler und ihrem Nachbarn
ist nicht mehr so eng wie zu Beginn.
Noch vor dem Verkauf
erhielt Ulf vom Vorbesitzer
einen Schlüssel für die Ferienanlage.
Seitdem geht Ulf hier ein und aus,
wie es ihm passt.
Ulf half anfangs immer ganz toll mit
und wir fragten uns,
welche Intention
wohl dahintersteckt.
Tut er das wirklich nur
für sein gutes Karma?
Tut er das einfach gern, weil
er ansonsten zu wenig zu tun hat,
oder steckt
irgendeine Absicht dahinter?
Eines Abends
rief er plötzlich an und meinte,
dass er hier gern
einen Shop eröffnen würde,
um Skis zu vermieten
oder zu verkaufen.
Es war von Anfang an sein Plan,
Geschäfte mit uns zu machen.
Wir hätten uns gewünscht,
dass er von Anfang an
offen kommuniziert hätte.
Ulfs Idee fand Familie Rotzler
eigentlich nicht schlecht.
Aber mit jedem weiteren Tag
benahm er sich ein wenig mehr
wie ein Mitbesitzer der Anlage.
Wir müssen irgendwo noch die Speise-
und die Getränkekarte aufhängen.
Du darfst mir helfen. Du kannst dich
an diesem Brett festhalten.
Anstelle von Ulf
geht Sabrina nun Jonas zur Hand.
Halt dich an diesem Brett fest.
Geh etwas zur Seite, zur Wand.
A4 ist etwas knapp.
- Nein, ich finde es okay.
Weisst du was?
- Senkrecht.
Wir nageln einen Ski an die Wand
und pinnen es an den Ski.
In den Lagerschuppen der Anlage
gibt es alte Ski zuhauf.
Bei Langläufern war Skalsjögarden
einst sehr beliebt.
Wieso hast du ihn entzweigesägt?
Wieso? Wegen der Bindung.
Bei der Bindung
schnitt ich ihn entzwei.
Willst du nicht?
- Nein.
Was machen wir sonst?
Einen ganzen Ski aufhängen.
- Das geht nicht.
Hier ist kein Platz.
- Wir hängen ihn schräg.
Du kannst die Menüs
doch nicht schräg hinhängen.
Schau mal,
er dürfte bis hierhin reichen.
Willst du ihn so aufhängen?
- Nein, andersrum.
Dann kann man es nicht lesen.
Verkehrt herum sieht es falsch aus.
Wir nehmen einen anderen Ski, nicht
den, den du entzweigeschnitten hast.
Es gibt keine
schönen, alten Skis mehr.
Er kann auch einfach nur alt sein.
Ich denke,
auf die Dauer ist es besser,
direkt und ehrlich zu sein,
als immer
um den heissen Brei herumzureden.
Ich bin gerade
ein bisschen schockiert.
Sabrina und Jonas versuchen,
Konflikte offen anzusprechen.
Das haben sie auch bei Nachbar Ulf
und seiner Frau Eva gemacht.
Offenbar mit Erfolg.
(Schwedisch)
Ja, das ist gut.
(Englisch)
Familie Rotzler will auch weiterhin
gut mit Ulf und Eva auskommen.
Was das Geschäft anbelangt, gehen sie
jedoch lieber ihren eigenen Weg.
Schau, was Papa macht.
So könnten wir das Menü aufhängen.
Auf dem griechischen Peloponnes
ruht bei Alain und Anita
für einmal die Arbeit.
Denn heute
erwarten die Auswanderer erste Gäste.
(Griechisch)
Eine Gruppe aus der Schweiz hat
bei ihnen eine Erlebnisreise gebucht.
Eine Woche lang
wollen Anita und Alain
den Reisenden
ihre neue Heimat zeigen.
(Englisch)
Wenn ich durchs Dorf
oder hier durch die Gegend gehe,
ist es, als wäre ich
schon immer hier gewesen.
Wirklich.
Trotz der Feuerkatastrophe:
Anita fühlt sich in Koroni wohl.
Es war nicht der Ort,
der mir kein Glück brachte.
Es war ein Waldbrand,
eine Katastrophe,
die mit dem Ort oder mit
dem Leben hier nichts zu tun hat.
Das ist einfach so.
Nun ist es unsere Aufgabe,
das Beste daraus zu machen.
(Griechisch)
Jassas.
* Kirchenglocken *
Noch ist hier alles im Winterschlaf.
Nur vereinzelt
verirren sich Touristen
in die Gassen des Fischerdorfes.
Ganz anders im Sommer: Dann
ist Koroni ein beliebter Ferienort.
* Mediterrane Musik *
Alain ist unterwegs
ins 50 km entfernte Kalamata.
Dort gibt es
einen internationalen Flughafen.
Ich hole zum ersten Mal
Gäste vom Flughafen ab.
Es wäre gelogen,
wenn ich behaupten würde,
ich wäre überhaupt nicht aufgeregt.
Ich bin schon ein bisschen nervös.
Immerhin: Die Hälfte der Gäste
kennt Alain bereits
aus der Reptilienszene.
Alain prüfte im Emmental
jahrelang elektrische Anlagen.
In Griechenland muss er sich nun
als Reiseleiter beweisen.
Hallo, Alain.
Salü, Rolf.
- Geht es dir gut?
Ja, tipptopp. Hallo, Brigitte.
- Hallo, Alain.
Hallo.
- Bist du Magrit?- Ja.
Alain.
Geht nur raus.
Dann können wir
die Masken abnehmen und sehen,
ob wir wirklich zusammengehören.
Hallo, Alain.
- Salü, Ruth.
Es ist schön, dich zu sehen.
- Hallo.
Es ist kühl bei euch.
- Ja, sehr kalt.
Die sechs Gäste sind Mitglieder
bei den Schildkrötenfreunden Aargau.
Nach dem Brand spendete der Verein
grosszügig für Alain und Anita -
so wie viele
andere Bekannte und Freunde.
Der Grösste kann vorn sitzen.
* Lachen *
Wollt ihr die Grossmutter
auch hinten platzieren?
Nein, hinten
gibt es nur zwei Plätze.
Die Schweizer kommen
zwei Monate früher als geplant -
auf eigenen Wunsch,
obwohl die Temperaturen
für die Reptilienbeobachtung
noch nicht ideal sind.
Tschau, ich bin Anita.
- Brigitte, freut mich.
Schön, dass du hier bist.
(Anita) Soll ich jemandem
beim Tragen helfen?
Alles gut.
Voilà, herzlich willkommen.
Ich lasse euch mal etwas ankommen.
Für die Gruppe haben Anita und Alain
ein Apartment gemietet.
In Zukunft wollen sie Gäste in fünf
eigenen Ferienhäuschen beherbergen.
Wir haben uns
sehr auf euch gefreut und hoffen,
dass das Wetter mitspielt,
damit wir viele Schildkröten finden.
Zudem hoffen wir, dass
angenehme Temperaturen herrschen,
wenn wir nachts oder tagsüber
unterwegs sind.
Herzlich willkommen.
- (Alle) Danke.
(Anita) Jámas.
- (Alle) Jámas.
Zum Wohl, schön, dass ihr hier seid.
Von einem gemütlichen Apéro
mit ersten Gästen
können die Auswanderer in Kanada
nur träumen.
Anstatt einzurichten, bangen Barbara
und Thomas weiterhin um ihre Möbel.
Die Zollbehörde hat
die Kontrolle zwar abgeschlossen,
den Container
aber immer noch nicht freigegeben.
Die endlose Warterei
zehrt an den Nerven.
Hier könnte man eigentlich
das ganze Papier entfernen.
Denn hier ist alles gestrichen.
In diesem Zimmer müssen nur noch
die Möbel platziert werden -
so Gott will
am Dienstag oder Mittwoch.
Hier könnten wir wirklich
mit der Tiefenreinigung beginnen.
Alles, was sie besitzen,
haben Barbara und Thomas in das
Projekt mit dem Gästehaus gesteckt.
Jetzt müssen sie so schnell
wie möglich Geld verdienen.
Hasenherz?
- Hm?
Ich weiss, wo du
mit Putzen anfangen könntest.- Hä?
Ich weiss,
wo du richtig putzen könntest.
Ich putze jetzt nicht, ich baue
dieses blöde Hundegitter auf.
Aber wenn du
das Gitter aufgebaut hast.
Dann ist 18 Uhr.
- Nein, ist es nicht.
Es ist noch nicht mal 12.30 Uhr.
- Was möchtest du mir erklären?
Die Sieben. Die Sieben ist - bis
aufs Badezimmer - komplett fertig.
Dort ist alles gestrichen
und die Schränke
sind zusammengebaut.
Dort ist alles perfekt.
Trotz sorgfältiger Planung
wird die To-do-Liste der beiden
einfach nicht kürzer.
Die Sieben müssen die Maler
nicht mehr betreten.
Hallo?
Hallo, Hase?
Den Zaun hat Barbara
im Internet bestellt.
Sobald ihr Gästehaus offen ist,
dürfen die Möpse nicht mehr frei
auf dem Gelände herumlaufen.
Was einfach aussieht,
ist bei diesen Bedingungen
jedoch alles andere als leicht.
Deswegen hören wir jetzt auf damit.
Dieses Problem kann ich an dieser
Stelle leider wirklich nicht lösen.
Die Idee ist gut,
aber es ist einfach zu windig
und ich habe im Moment
keine Lösung dafür.
Ich habe einfach keine.
* Kläffen *
Gell, Duffy, tut mir leid.
Wir müssen uns
etwas anderes überlegen.
Ich bin in der Sieben.
Das Zaunprojekt
ist so nicht realisierbar.
Ich habe keine Lösung.
Ich kümmere mich
jetzt um die Sieben. Danke.
Die knappe Zeit, der wirtschaftliche
Druck, die viele Arbeit:
Thomas hat sich den Start
ihres Gästehauses anders vorgestellt.
6.30 Uhr in der Früh in Schweden.
Magst du etwas essen?
- Nein.
Du bist noch müde, nicht wahr?
Es ist auch noch früh.
Du musst dich erst umgewöhnen.
Das Fieber ist weg und Fiona ist
fit genug für ihren ersten Schultag.
Ich bin eigentlich nicht nervös.
Ich freue mich für Fiona.
Sie wird tolle Freunde finden.
Ich bin überzeugt,
dass sie es gut machen wird.
(Fiona) Tschüss.
- (Silvana) Tschau.
Ich koche ein leckeres Mittagessen,
okay?
Spaghetti mit Tomatensauce.
Also, gehen wir?
- Viel Spass.
In der Schweiz könnte Fiona
zu Fuss zur Primarschule gehen.
Das nächste Schulhaus
in Schweden jedoch
ist rund 25 km entfernt.
Ich denke,
das ist der richtige Ort für sie.
Es ist eine kleine Schule, wo es
verhältnismässig wenige Kinder gibt
und wo jeder jeden kennt - auch über
die verschiedenen Klassen hinweg.
Auch in Bezug auf das Lehrpersonal
ist es wohl genau das Richtige.
* Ruhige Musik *
Schau, ein Fuchs, dort.
Er wollte die Strasse überqueren.
Das ist ein gutes Zeichen, Fiona.
- Das war ein Glücksfuchs.
* Ruhige Musik *
An der Viksjöfors skola
werden knapp 50 Kinder unterrichtet.
Hast du die Farben gesehen?
Gelb und rot.
- Schau, Ballone.
Und dort steht "Willkommen".
Hej, hej.
Klassenlehrerin Viktoria
erwartet Fiona bereits.
* Viktoria spricht schwedisch. *
- Ja.
Hm?
- Schön, dass du wieder gesund bist.
Sehen wir es uns an?
Schau.
Jetzt heisst es:
Rechnen, Lesen, Schreiben lernen -
und das alles auf Schwedisch.
* Die Kinder und Viktoria
sprechen schwedisch. *
Ich bin hier. Setz dich hin.
Alles gut, alles gut.
Danach hörst du zu,
was Viktoria sagt, okay?
Ich kann noch kein Schwedisch.
- Du verstehst es sicher.
Du kannst anfangen,
die Rakete zu zeichnen.
Damit es Fiona leichter fällt,
hat Sabrina mit ihr bereits
seit einigen Wochen Schwedisch geübt.
Bis später.
Hm?
- Bleib noch hier drinnen.
* Ruhige Musik *
Unbemerkt von Fiona
schleicht sich Sabrina davon.
Ich kann nicht
die ganze Zeit bei ihr sein.
Das ist für sie jetzt vielleicht
total hart - und für mich auch -,
aber es ist besser so.
Sonst will sie die ganze Zeit meine
Hand halten und das geht nicht.
Die Blumen können fast
ein wenig darüber hinwegtäuschen,
wie kühl es noch immer ist.
Kaum 15 °C im Schatten zeigt
das Thermometer in Griechenland.
Wollen wir noch
zu dieser Mauer gehen, Alain?
Das können wir gern tun.
- Wollen wir dort nachsehen?
Alain und Anita führen
die Reisegruppe auf eine Exkursion.
Soll ich vorangehen?
- Ja.
Alain möchte mit der Gruppe
Reptilien aufspüren.
Wer die dünnsten Hosen trägt,
geht zuhinterst.
Echsen zeigen sich meist zuerst.
Man sieht sie eigentlich immer,
zumindest beim Verschwinden.
Aber hier ist nichts.
Der Stein ist allerdings warm.
- (Mann) Der Stein ist warm.
Aber die Temperatur
ist wohl zu wenig homogen.
Aber so schnell gibt Alain nicht auf.
Er weiss genau, wo er suchen muss.
Hallo, hier ist eine Schildkröte.
* Pfiff *
(Anita) Schildkröte!
Sieh an.
(Anita) Ich vermutete, dass Rolf
als Erster etwas sehen würde.
Er hat einen gewissen Ruf.
Wie war das? Wer als Erster etwas
findet, bezahlt das Abendessen?
(Anita) Der schmeisst eine Runde.
- Vielen Dank.
Bitte.
Schön, wir haben
die erste Schildkröte gefunden.
Nun suchen wir die Nächste.
* Verträumte Musik *
Das geht gut.
Das kommt gut.
Mit ihren Gästen
wollen Alain und Anita
zu einem versteckten Wasserfall.
Als sie das letzte Mal dort waren,
wimmelte es
im Wasser von Schildkröten.
Die Schildkröten sind dort hinten.
Mauremys rivulata.
Westkaspische Schildkröten
leben am Fuss des Wasserfalls.
Hier drin sind sie jeweils.
Ansonsten sind sie dort hinten.
Alains geschultem Auge
entgeht kein Tier.
Diesmal aber ...
Nichts.
Hier sonnen sich keine Schildkröten.
Peinlich.
Dann beschränken wir uns
auf die Landschaft.- Genau.
Aber es ist schön, nicht wahr?
- Ja, klar.
Hier waren jeweils
eine Menge Krabben und Frösche.
Aber heute sieht man nichts.
- Es ist zu kalt.
Aber Frösche ...
- Frösche könnte es schon geben.
* Kinder rufen durcheinander. *
An der Viksjöfors skola in Schweden
hat Fiona eine Lektion draussen.
Im Kindergarten in Witterswil
mochte sie das am liebsten.
* Beschwingte Musik aus Lautsprecher,
fröhliche Kinderrufe *
Die Kinder sind bis
am frühen Nachmittag in der Schule.
Doch heute holt Sabrina ihre Tochter
schon kurz vor dem Mittagessen ab.
So hat es Sabrina mit Klassenlehrerin
Viktoria vereinbart.
Wir malten die schweizerische
und die schwedische Flagge aus.
* Viktoria spricht schwedisch. *
Möchtest du es mitnehmen?
Darf ich?
- Ja, du darfst es mitnehmen.
* Viktoria spricht schwedisch. *
Es ging sehr gut.
Tack sa mycket.
(Fiona)
Hej da, Viktoria.
In der ersten Woche wird Sabrina
ihre Tochter mit dem Auto fahren.
Dann soll Fiona den Schulbus nehmen.
Ging es gut? Ja?
Hey, super.
Ich will nicht nochmals gehen.
- Willst du nochmals gehen?- Nein.
Ich habe hier
eine ganz hungrige junge Dame.
Ich habe sogar schon gekocht.
- Wow! Hast du Hunger?
Mal sehen.
Sie sagte, sie habe Spass gehabt
und es sei nicht so schlimm gewesen,
aber morgen wolle
sie trotzdem nicht hin.
Aber es ist ein guter Anfang.
Möchtest du Tomatensauce?
- Ja.
Der erste Schultag ist geschafft.
Jonas und Sabrina hoffen,
dass sich Fiona schnell
in der neuen Schule einleben wird.
(Fiona) Wir wünschen
allen hier guten Appetit.
(Jonas und Sabrina) Guten Appetit.
* Mediterrane Musik *
Nach Sonnenuntergang unternehmen
Anita und Alain in Griechenland
einen neuen Anlauf.
Diesmal suchen sie mit
ihrer Reisegruppe nach Chamäleons.
* Mediterrane Musik *
Worauf man achten muss?
Ob man im Licht der Taschenlampe
einen hellgelben Fleck sieht.
Manchmal ist es Papier
und manchmal ist es ein kleines
oder ein grosses Chamäleon.
Wenn es dunkel ist,
kann man Chamäleons besser sehen.
Dann heben sie sich
von der Umgebung ab -
so zumindest die Theorie.
Bis jetzt sieht man noch nichts.
Alain würde sich
über ein Erfolgserlebnis freuen.
Aber auch hier ist es anscheinend
für die Tiere noch zu kalt.
Auf einmal
macht sich Aufregung breit.
Siehst du es?
- Ein solches Ding sehe ich nicht.
(Mann) Wenn man weiss,
worauf man achten muss ...
Das ist ein Kleines, nicht wahr?
- Ja, ja.
(Anita) Das Hellgrüne, genau.
Ein Baby-Chamäleon.
(Rolf) Wir sprechen von einem aus
Afrika eingeschleppten Chamäleon.
Ich dachte nicht, dass sie
bei dieser Kälte draussen sind.
V.a. so weit vorn. Gut, ja, super.
(Mann) Gar nicht schlecht.
- (Anita) Alain fand das Grosse.
Das Basiliskenchamäleon
gibt es in Europa nur an diesem Ort.
Sein eigentlicher Lebensraum
liegt in Afrika.
Das war für mich das Ziel der Reise.
Nun ist es erfüllt.
* Jubel, Lachen *
Ich halte die Lampe zu.
Der Wind in Kanada ist weg
und der Hundezaun steht.
Der Container mit den Möbeln aber
fehlt nach wie vor.
Und ohne Möbel keine Eröffnung.
Bis zur Ankunft der ersten Gäste
bleiben Thomas und Barbara
nur noch zwei Tage.
Es beeinflusst unsere Stimmung
und unseren Umgang miteinander.
Man muss sich wirklich fragen:
Warum um alles in der Welt
tun wir uns das eigentlich an?
Ist es das wirklich wert?
Und: Als hätten die beiden
nicht schon genug Probleme,
taucht ein weiteres auf.
In den Gästezimmern
gibt es kein heisses Wasser.
Die Installation der fabrikneuen
Durchlauferhitzer scheint in Ordnung.
Doch wo liegt der Fehler?
(Mann)
(Anita)
Das Problem:
Es gab ein Missverständnis
zwischen Sanitär und Elektriker.
Gut, dass wir das heute erfahren. So
kann man wirklich noch etwas ändern.
Der Elektriker
hat zu dünne Stromkabel verlegt.
Kein heisses Wasser und keine Möbel.
Schlimmer kann es
fast nicht mehr kommen.
(Combox) You have one new message.
Wenigstens etwas Positives:
Der Container
kann heute abgeholt werden.
Ein Problem ist gelöst,
dafür steht das nächste vor der Tür.
Es bleibt spannend.
- (Lachend) Ja.
Ein Wechselbad der Gefühle:
Die beiden
brauchen weiterhin starke Nerven.
Wir können es eh nicht ändern.
- Es ist so abstrus lächerlich.
Die ganze Nummer
ist völlig hirnrissig.
In der nächsten Folge treffen
nach langem Warten die Möbel ein.
Ein riesiger Überseecontainer
randvoll mit Kartons.
* Ächzen *
Barbara und Thomas bleiben weniger
als 36 Std., um alles einzurichten.
Ich gebe einfach nicht auf.
- So ...
Der alles entscheidende Faktor.
Um die Gäste zu begeistern,
ist mindestens eine davon nötig.
In Griechenland
bereiten Alain und Anita
die Bodenplatte für die Maurer vor.
Der Wiederaufbau ihres Wohnhauses
soll jetzt
so schnell wie möglich starten.
Bezüglich der Subventionen
haben wir eine mündliche Zusage
unseres Architekten.
Endlich ein richtiges Daheim
bekommen die Wasserschildkröten.
Die Emmentaler feiern die Einweihung
der Teiche mit einem Fest.
Und los.
Hui!
Und erster Schnee in Schweden.
Jonas muss die Langlaufloipen
für die Gäste präparieren.
Es ist eigentlich ein Vergnügen.
Ich stehe gern um 6 Uhr auf.
Familie Rotzler
organisiert einen Weihnachtsmarkt
für die lokale Bevölkerung.
Das Restaurant im Skalsjögarden
ist so voll wie noch nie.
Man schafft es kaum,
es rechtzeitig aufzufüllen.
# U sie stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüm meh hei.
# U sie löh hie aues zrugg,
uf de Suechi für nes neus Dahei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo, yeah.